-Welcome back, everybody. I'm
here with Lin-Manuel Miranda!
Now, his --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's talk about
"In The Heights."
This is the movie adaptation
of your Tony-winning
Broadway musical.
You started writing this
when you were in college.
You were 19
when you were writing this.
And what did you envision
when you were --
when you were writing this?
-Yeah, I was not much older than
"The King of Wishful Thinking"
-Exactly.
-...that you saw.
But I -- I honestly --
I just -- I knew I wanted
a life in musicals.
I directed "West Side Story"
my senior year of high school,
and I knew that was kind of it
for Puerto Rican guys
in musical theater.
That's all that existed.
-Yeah.
-I love that show.
-That's interesting.
-But it was a long time ago.
And -- And I just kind of
was writing what was missing.
And I wanted to, you know,
I wanted to write musicals
starring Latinos,
telling different stories and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Like, and here we are
20 years later, right?
And now I'm on "The Tonight
Show" talking to you.
Like, that's crazy!
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, that's --
It shows how much work
goes into all of this stuff.
-Yeah.
-Lightning in a --
I mean, come on.
-Yeah.
-And don't stop.
And you never stopped.
And you just go, "We're just
gonna keep doing this.
I'm going to write this."
And it is brilliantly done.
The choreography, the singing.
Anthony Ramos.
-What a superstar.
Superstar!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's just -- It's colorful.
It moves. It's hopeful.
It's a beautiful story.
And, yeah, it just gives you
everything you want to see
in a movie.
I loved it. I needed it.
Like, I need a film --
I love "Godzilla vs. Kong."
That's all good.
I need this, though. I needed
this. And I was like, "Oh."
And then, there's a scene
where it's like,
"Oof, this is going to get sad.
You're not going to do it."
And yeah, it does.
It gets you, and you go, "Oh."
It's so great.
But I just -- I freaked out.
But when I talked to you, when
Jon was doing the movie, you go,
"Yeah, and I think I might -- I
might do something in the movie.
You were not going to be in it.
-I was not going to be in it.
I was -- I was never
planning to be in it.
I had my Broadway experience,
which was a miraculous
experience.
I went from substitute teacher
to Broadway composer.
I will never make a leap
that big again in my life.
And, so, I was very content
to let Anthony Ramos
and this incredible cast
kind of have
their own experience.
And Quiara, my co-writer, and
Jon Chu, kept dropping hints,
like, "We haven't cast
Piragua Guy yet.
We haven't cast Piragua Guy
yet."
And I was like, "That's cool.
That's cool."
And then Quiara
said two things --
She wrote the screenplay,
and she's a genius.
But she also said, "I think that
we might have to cut Piragua,
because it doesn't really
move the plot along.
But I thought of a way
not to cut it."
And I went, "What is the way?
I love that song."
And she said,
"If you play Piragua Guy,
they won't cut Piragua Guy."
-You can't cut Piragua Guy!
-Yeah.
-He's my favorite.
Dude, the song is so good.
-Yeah.
-It pays off.
-Yeah. And she also said, like,
"If you hadn't written this,
you'd be begging
to be in this movie.
This is what
you always dreamed of."
And, like, that kind of
got through to me.
And I'm so glad I was a part
of it, because it's just --
I'm so proud of what Jon made.
And there's a moment
where I sing with Anthony,
and he played my old part,
and I get to duet with him.
And I'm on a fire escape,
and he's a floor below me,
and I'm singing a new harmony,
and he's singing my old harmony.
And there's all these,
like, full-circle moments.
It was really --
It was like a dream come true.
Every day was a dream come true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's so well written.
It's so good.
And you go, yeah,
at the end, you're clapping,
even though I was
watching at home,
and I was just, like, clapping
by -- I was like, "Oh, my God."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lin-Manuel Miranda
in "In The Heights."
Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Singing in Spanish ]
♪♪
-[ Singing in Spanish ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's that --
It's how you feel it.
It's so well done.
I also want to say, the --
Tomorrow night, it opens
the Tribeca Film Festival,
which means a lot
to New York City,
but also to everyone
in the business,
I mean, what they've done
with that festival.
But you're opening
the film festival.
You're going to be
in Washington Heights
showing this to a theater.
-We premiere this movie
on 175th Street, y'all.
Like, it's in
Washington Heights.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The best --
That -- Talk about emotional.
That's like --
It is a love letter
to Washington Heights, really,
and New York City.
And I think that's going
to be another special moment.
-It's going to be insane.
-Buddy, I love you so much.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
We love you. Lin-Manuel Miranda.
"In The Heights" is in theaters
and on HBO Max this Thursday.